we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 for 750
uh name in town that's really all I'm
concerned with and then I'd love to
answer your question or your comment
who's next on the line today hello hello
yeah you're on who are we talking to
todd todd were you calling from calling
from across the border in Ontario Canada
right and it is my pleasure to take your
call what's on your mind uh well first
of all I give you a pat on the back for
taking calls I I think it's great and
it'd be nice to see some other shows
some of yours do the same thing is show
some guts I um and I want to talk about
third parties okay and the whole idea of
why one should vote for a third party or
not okay because I find it really
disturbing i think that the necessity to
form a respectable third party that can
compete with you know the two existing
parties is probably the number one
priority for US citizens looking to
improve their government its that's my
opinion okay i think it's even more
important than refuting sis united which
is a close second well these two issues
are related right i mean the way in
which politics is funded is very
directly related to why we basically
have two viable at least at the national
level parties in the united states my
solution is really a two-part solution
and it's really a pie-in-the-sky
solution at this point which is we need
to completely reef redo campaign finance
and we can't have the system that we
currently have but we also need Instant
Runoff voting so that more people would
say you know what I now have there's no
risk to me of helping the candidate I
really don't want by voting for a third
party candidate because I can say my
primary choice is whoever from from
whatever party if that person is not
viable after a first count of the
ballots then switch my vote to the
other candidate and in this way you can
actually not fall into what some people
call the Ross Perot or Ralph Nader
situation right the idea that the third
party can you that you really like is
actually going to prevent your second
choice from winning so I that's my path
forward and good good luck moving
forward on it i mean it's we're so
entrenched in the exact opposite of what
i described that i just don't see it you
know what's super interesting theory I
you know I'm a math god I've never
really put that to the numbers test and
I'm gonna dig into it when I get off the
phone here but well my point is is that
it really bothers me when I hear people
saying all that third party vote is a
wasted vote or if you vote for somebody
it's going to help somebody else because
although that may be true to some degree
i think it's far more important
especially during this election to
establish uh momentum for a third party
candidate yeah i don't disagree with you
although at the same time uh i I've
looked at the numbers and it is possible
that there are states in which the third
the presence of the third party
candidates could actually flip the
result of that state and I attend I
think I'm probably a little more
pragmatic than you now that we're at the
the final point but we'll have to
disagree on that for the time being
please do run the numbers on the Instant
Runoff voting and call back in if you
discover anything interesting about it a
lot about it written online thank you so
much for the call I do have to move on
we are taking calls today at six 17 8 30
for 750